um you know I I kind of don't maybe it's
just a matter of semantics but faking it
till you make it is like pretending you
can't do something full-on acting and
then hopefully it'll catch up and I
don't believe in that what I do believe
in is pushing your limits so for example
I've seen it done in meetings from other
people I've definitely done it when
somebody in a meeting says can you do
this and you think to yourself
oh that's gonna be hard if I were
responsible I'd be like uh no that's too
hard or that's too aggressive but I've
gone yes yes I can do that and then I've
gone and pushed my boundaries and
realized I'm actually capable of doing
that so I do believe in pushing
boundaries I do believe in
over-promising and then actually
delivering so if that's fake until you
make it sure but I think it's more like
push your boundaries and realize you're
capable of more